[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Violet McGraw who
stars in Megan which is in theaters now
Violet how you doing today
I'm good how are you
I'm doing great I'm so honored to be
with you here uh I absolutely love this
film excited for people to see it now so
what was your first reaction when you
read this script like what did you feel
coming off the page for you
well when I when I read the script I
thought it was a really cool fun new
idea and that's why I was really excited
when I booked it because I could not
wait to be a part of that fun new idea
so and I think people are really gonna
like this because I think they're gonna
want Megan as their best friend you know
oh yeah for sure that's what's really
cool about it and seeing that
relationship between Katie and Megan now
were you always going to play Katie did
you ever like audition for anyone else
like Megan or anything like that I was
um just auditioning for Katie oh cool
okay cool yeah no and it's the perfect
part for you it's just awesome and it's
interesting I think what people are
going to wonder about this film is the
scenes you have with the doll Megan what
were you actually seeing on set like is
the actress Amy Donald there with you
like what are you talking to well at
Parts obviously they found a new voice
for Megan but um when I was there they
sometimes had like a actual like robot
there that they controlled and the
director would just like say her lines
so that way I would just like get the
timing right but if I was ever doing a
scene with Amy when she's in the costume
she would actually say the lines even if
we weren't gonna hear her voice she
still had to say the line so I would
know when to semi yeah did you find that
one of the more challenging experiences
you've had on a film set because you
already have a big resume here so was
that kind of interesting trying to find
that emotional connection in that sense
I guess I mean at first I was like a
little a little creeped out by the doll
and then she's like very disturbing but
I think as I was on set more with her I
think it got a lot easier and I kind of
like became best friends with her that's
really cool and yeah it shows on screen
you really pull off that relationship so
Props to you now was it really exciting
for you you had posted pictures on your
Instagram of this big premiere for the
film was that a wild experience and Was
it crazy seeing the doll dancers
I loved seeing the doll dancers I
thought that was a really fun touch that
they did and that red carpet like that
was really fun because Amy um Amy Donald
lives in New Zealand and it was I was
just really excited to see her there
again because she lives so far away but
I really loved the red carpet and that
Premiere I think that was probably one
of my favorite premieres because that
was like really special yeah it was
really cool and it really added to just
excitement for the film too which I
liked and not only the excitement for
the film but even after that Premiere
how did it feel to see critics not only
praising the film but praising your
performance in particular I thought it
was very sweet of them and I I really
appreciate that because I I obviously
want to keep doing acting but that
definitely makes me still want to
accomplish my dreams and keep going in
the future
yeah and it's awesome how much you've
already accomplished and accomplished
some of these dreams I would say for a
lot of people where I mean I first
noticed you in Haunting of Hill House
playing my favorite character of Nell so
you know you've been in a good amount of
horror already so are you a fan yourself
of watching horror are you scared by it
like what are your feelings when you
watch a horror film I love scary things
now at first I wasn't really a fan but
like since I've been in probably a like
a lot of scary films I know how it like
all works and how everything goes on so
I definitely have become a big horror
fan I think
oh that's great yeah and it's cool you
get to see the behind the scenes and I
think it's really cool that you've
already worked with the Mike Flanagan
and now a James Wan was there anything
you just learned from being on sets like
that like the main takeaway working with
these like big Legends in the industry
yes I definitely learned a lot I learned
he he always taught he was always so
patient with me so he definitely taught
like Mike Flanagan was always so patient
with me because I was like six at the
time but he always taught me to just
really be vacation and I think I've
learned also a lot from my older sister
Maddie because she she's done this
longer than me but we def we always give
each other like tips like she tells me
to just really listen be in the moment
and respond honestly in a scene
yeah that's really cool so you're really
close with sister Maddie and it's
awesome she's having this horror success
to a black hole so that must just be
wild for you too kind of getting to bond
over that right yes that's awesome so is
there any particular actors or actresses
who Inspire craft currently
um well my sister definitely inspires me
she definitely tells me to just keep
going
um Allison Williams for sure she's
amazing and probably like a lot like
everyone I've worked with because
everyone I've worked with has been
amazingly talented so I think everyone
has just been supporting me this whole
time and they definitely have been like
very appreciative and supportive so if
you think this is why I'm still acting
yeah for sure that that's great and it's
good you're learning from that and it
really shows that you're just
professional just even in this interview
so it props to you so what your Twitter
which is really cool your Twitter bio
says you're a big soccer fan so do you
play and did you watch any of the World
Cup I do play a soccer I am on a club
team I thought for like almost almost
three years now but I did I also did I
did watch the World Cup but uh I was I
was voting for France because
I was a little sad because the World Cup
is like only every three and a half
years but I I'm still very proud of
France because they they did really good
that's awesome no cool yeah and they did
do really good and
um I'm gonna ask you too the question
that's gonna be I think on everyone's
mind you're the one to answer who wins
in a fight
Megan or Chucky
I don't know they're like I've never
seen Chucky but they're both such great
villains so I have no idea but I think
they're both such great villains so yeah
no for sure
um so last question I have for you too
is what do you think like just people
you know who are going to see this film
what do you want to take from it the
most like what feelings you want to see
them come out of the theater with like
scared excited what do you feel I think
it's they're going to be like excited
because I think they'll like Megan a lot
again like they want her as their best
friend and I think they're gonna be a
little bit creeped out because she can
be disturbing sometimes but like I think
people are really going to like this and
I think they're going to be very proud
and they're all going to be like I wish
Megan was real
I love that and I'm excited to see more
of these if they come so everybody watch
Violet crush it and Megan which is in
theaters now Violet thank you so much
for joining me today and I hope to talk
to you in the future thank you so much
for having me